i don't normally do this like i don't
normally just i'm not normally myself on
camera funny you should mention that
because i'm not normally someone else
okay so for me it's super uncomfortable
i'm gonna do the intro okay good morning
hank it's tuesday i am joined by
isabella merced the star of turtles all
the way down she plays asa she's
brilliant i'm with john and he is an
amazing
writer but also he's an actor today is
the day that we're filming my cameo and
is so physically uncomfortable how does
acting work acting is a weird thing to
be into because
you can't just do it whenever you can't
like singing you can just start singing
right and someone goes oh you sing sing
a song
oh you act act something like you can't
just do that you're very very good you
were just her for me
and you and now like when i think of her
i think of you as her that's such as
awesome like an awesome thing to hear as
an actor because that's just so
reassuring and that's all we look for
like literally we're in this career path
because we need reassurance from people
and like affirmation it's true for
writers as well yeah so it's like
amazing to hear that from the person who
created it i'm curious about that
because i i wondered what you envisioned
in your head like what did aza have a
face for you
for a minute that's a great question not
really no um she was just using
a little that's a little too close it's
too good i also kind of like copied you
right i kind of copied the way you talk
in a way when we filmed probably like
the most difficult scene in the whole
movie which was in my opinion the climax
of the movie with the hand sanitizer i
don't even remember doing that like i
just blacked out in that moment
i can't remember it was the weirdest
thing it was painful i just wanted to
like stop it and like turn all the
lights on and
make sure everyone was okay
i was really
as the papa in you yeah yeah that was
probably the dad in me but also i think
i can
feel
empathy for aza
that i struggle to feel for myself when
i'm really sick a lot of times i
struggle to show myself that same kind
of compassion that's so true yeah i've
learned that from this for sure that i
need to give myself a break that was
intense so now i have to think about
questions i want to ask you
light-hearted ones um oh yeah okay i got
i've got a lighthearted one okay um
what's your favorite color
oh uh i
think sage green sage green yeah and
what who is your favorite member of the
rock band the beatles oh no i watched
your video with god i can't even catch
you with this one all right well we're
not gonna the beatles thing isn't gonna
play
wait what's your favorite color green
green
it's mine it's my whole identity is it
actually your favorite color
that's a great question it's a
predetermined thing i don't i don't know
you don't there's some really deep blues
i like almost like a sky when the sky is
almost the sky when the sun is yes on
the farthest end of the sky
i have a new favorite color i have dad
who's been in therapy since the age of
13 energy so like any time my kids are
talking to me about feelings i'm always
like leaning i wonder when i'm a parent
i'm always going to want them to share
things but i also don't want to look too
desperate oh that's so true that is so
well put how do you do that
i don't know because i come across as
super desperate and they can sense it
yeah like they sense it and they back
away
what's your favorite animal
humans what about you i like dogs i
think i can oh your dog is the best i
can place a bed on dogs i love your dog
i take it back my favorite
species of animal is your dog
oh bella has to get back to work
so we are and also i guess i have to get
back to work oh you're gonna yeah hank
i'll see you on friday